It’s wonderful to be in a room
with so many humans
after all this time.
In the last few years,
I've been keeping company
with a new species
that happens to live in the air.
And I'd like you all to meet
my aerobe friend.
(Music)
(Music ends)
(Cheers and applause)
I get emotional every time I see it fly.
In my work as an artist,
I ask a lot of questions
about the world around me.
While the problems of the world
don't have easy solutions,
I think it's as important
to ask the right questions.
Why do our technologies
instill so much fear in us?
Why do our lives today feel so alienating,
when our technologies
are supposed to improve our lives?
And why do we feel so disconnected,
when our inventions are meant to connect
each and every one of us?
My artwork deals with evolution,
biology and the senses.
I'm interested in how organisms
are composed of different life-forms,
such as bacteria, fungi and viruses ...
but also how different chemical
and molecular interactions can happen
whenever we simply take a breath.
So I've always found modern technology
to be quite limiting
because of how cold and flat it is.
But what if our machines
could be more holistic?
And what if our machines
could relate to us in a more holistic way?
could be more than just our tools,
and instead, a new type
of companion species?
I believe we need to embrace
who we are as symbiotic living beings,
and design machines to reflect this.
What if the world
was populated by machines
that were more like animals and plants,
instead of something
you'd find in a factory?
This exploration could teach us
so much more about life,
in all its vast complexities.
These ideas might sound
like mere science fiction,
but my mission as an artist is to create
possibilities of other worlds,
and other ways of living and being,
even if just for a moment.
So when I was invited to imagine
a large-scale installation
at the Tate Modern in London,
I decided to make this world
I'm describing a reality.
The museum space is incredibly vast,
and I knew right away
that I wanted to transform it
into an aquarium of machines.
I asked myself,
"What would it feel like to live
in the world with machines
that could live in the wild
and evolve on their own?"
To explore this question,
I created two new machine species
that I call "aerobes."
I released 12 aerobes
into the museum space
so they could form
their own small ecosystem.
In order to minimize
our human-centric biases,
and to steer clear
of simply mimicking the human form,
I worked with my team
to look at the natural world,
and we were inspired
by creatures like the comb jellyfish
and the lion's mane mushroom.
We also looked deeply
into the field of soft robotics,
and ultimately brought the aerobes to life
by designing them with fluid movement
and lighter-than-air construction.
When you look at these aerobes,
it gives you a feeling almost opposite
to the uncanny valley.
You know that they're mechanical,
yet they feel palpably alive.
You feel like you might be next
to some majestic and remote life-form.
Like swimming next to a humpback whale.
Their size is imposing ...
yet they inspire an emotion
closer to awe than to fear.
You sense that they're almost living,
and it makes you want to embrace
and coexist with them,
to see them truly succeed.
I wanted the aerobes
to have a sense of freedom
and unpredictability,
so I worked with my team
to create what is called
an artificial life simulation.
This software allows each aerobe
to develop unique behaviors
and to respond autonomously
to its environment.
The aerobes evolve their personalities
as they interact
and learn from each other.
The more we flew them,
the more we got to know
their distinct personalities
and their gentle nature.
It was very important for me
that the aerobes
had their own sensory world.
Most AI functions like a mind
without a body.
But all living creatures,
from the humble tick
to the stealthy panther,
learn about the world
through their bodies and their senses.
These aerobes perceive each other
through high-frequency radio waves,
and they use thermal sensing
to detect other living creatures
in their environment.
An aerobe might be curious
about your heat signature,
and fly over to greet and flirt with you,
while other aerobes are more shy
and might go out of their way
to avoid a crowd.
How will these machines and humans
be together in the world?
What will this world look like?
This world may see machines and humans
generating new intimacies
and alternate perspectives.
My hope is that these aerobes
will help us appreciate
a more diverse way of living and being.
Their purpose is not
to compete with us or to dominate us,
but to ask what a more compatible
future could look like.
We all have a stake in this conversation
about technologies.
Can we actively align machines
to better reflect our biological reality?
I sincerely hope that you'll consider
that machines can be so much more
than what we've known,
and how they might embody
a wisdom drawn from biology.
This project is a project for everybody,
to imagine different worlds
and different futures.
It's not too late to change
machine evolution
and to consider new goals,
where machines and humans can coexist
in a more compassionate way.
I believe this is where we can
start the conversation.
(Applause)
(Music)
(Music ends)
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)